ensuite allez on va faire le conseil de
presse gilles garder santé pmp ça donne
ça
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez c'est avant tout la joie
de vivre incarnée tu es très mauvaise
humeur
un élève qui met une bonne ambiance dans
la classe toujours très sympa avec ses
camarades arrivés
regardez moi ne fuyez pas vous êtes un
privilégié sans morale ni éthique aulas
et quand on voit comme ça 5 ça gueule ça
fait des mois jean-michel que tu nous
emmerdes avec ta bouche que tu vas faire
au théâtre était pas capable d'articuler
trois mots qui va nous emmerder sûr
surtout avec sa voisine isabelle je
trouve qu'elle est on s'en fout et
étoiles été toilettée droit mais les
toits si on fait le calcul de
probabilités comme higuain bref pour
résumer gilles verdez dans tpm paix à
nanterre nom isabelle c'est plutôt un
journaliste engagé avec des avis
tranchés très tranchées et j'ai détesté
c'est une catastrophe que le flop du
siècle même calamité télévisuelle qui en
une saison a réussi à se mettre à dos
tous le peuvent
je pense que laurence boccolini c'est la
télé du passé renault guillon c'est l'un
des pires ça marche pas parce que c'est
bon gros qui présente lui posté par un
bon animateur avec delphine ernotte
c'est la catastrophe france télévisions
mais gilles verdez c'est aussi un énorme
bosseur
gilles verdez vous a donc été j'ai
enquêté moi j'ai parlé avec lui
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous montrer
quelques chiffres des déguisements de
qualité est l'exemple à marquise de
pompadour
[Applaudissements]
et des histoires passionnantes nous
sommes en 1993 en écosse sur les bords
du loch ness
je vais une amourette naissante avec
catherine que je viens de rencontrer
pour ça vous intéresse l'emballer bref
pour la cinquième saison consécutive
gilles nous a régalés dans tpm fait et
ça ça mérite une petite danse de la joie
on vous avez une souris dans le si
[Applaudissements]
souvent de mauvaise foi particulièrement
excessif est généralement très obstiné
tu nous énerve les élèves pendant les
débats et mais aussi tu es nerveux les
téléspectateurs n'êtes pas parti trop
vite
[Rires]
si en plus vous mais oui oui et donc
voila tu énerve les téléspectateurs lors
ce qui me croisent dans la rue ils
disent il est vraiment comme ça je
regardais ce oui il est comme ça et
parfois tu tires volontairement les
choses pour par provocation
en revanche tu t'améliores sur les deux
mains du cirill tu ne cries pu c'est
vachement bien tuer beaucoup plus
audible je ne dirais pas encore
crédibles sur tous les sujets mais
presque il ya du mieux
enfin tu as compris que ce n'est pas
celui qui crie qui a raison sur tes pmp
tu est essentielle à trouver un bosseur
précis investits donne à 100% au coeur
des débats tu prends souvent le sens
contraire
parler c'est quoi moi humainement d'un
garçon d'une grande gentillesse d'une
grande bienveillance et surtout de très
bons conseils non seulement je tu
abordes tu adores et lui confie une
totale confiance en toi c'est pourquoi
je te mets un oeuf sony
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi les gentils hashtags user
[Rires]
gilles verdez vous êtes un objet
télévisuel non identifié vous êtes
étrange vous êtes perché vous êtes une
sorte d'extraterrestre vous êtes
aveuglés par votre démagogie vous criez
avant d'être en colère
c'est donc insupportable autour de ce
plateau pour moi finalement comparé
nabila à marilyn monroe les chevaliers
du fiel a dit berkman et les marseillais
à un documentaire sociétal chez de
brasles c'est absurde ça n'a aucun sens
mais pour autant j'aime la contradiction
j'aime que tpm paix soit un plateau
justement de liberté d'expression et
pour ça je vous fais mais je vous mets
un magnifique 7 avec ce que vos amis je
l'aurais défoncé ah non mais sans
rigoler être castaldi gilles je ne sais
par où commencer
j'aurais tout ce qu'il ya derrière ces
femmes n'ont j'apprécie absolument
toucher vous votre sens mesurer des
propos votre façon vraiment toujours
france de dire les choses
le fait que vous aimez le monde entier
vous êtes toujours tendre avec les
légendes du paf
franchement vous êtes d'entre nous le
meilleur incontestablement et pour
toutes ces raisons là droit dans les
yeux gilles verdez je vous mets un
fabuleux 0
zéro et pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas
mais vous le trouvez groupe a pas du
tout en outre une nuit à merci et
voulait me convient boisjoly en 06
abacha alors moi j'ai une position
apparente verges il parce que j'ai une
position géographique appart par rapport
à lui chez juste à côté
comme l'a fait perdre trois points
auditifs afin de porter son total 22
fois une porte sur les nerfs aussi à
part ça je vous aime vraiment
profondément à l'extérieur j'ai envie de
vous frapper quand vous êtes à côté
et vous savez la tendresse que je vous
porte et mais un splendide cinq et demi
que je crée très bientôt
chroniqueur en faisant le show en
acceptant toutes les postures les plus
invraisemblables qu'on te demande
d'adopter tu as des habits très tranché
ce qui al'avantage de ne pas te mettre
de placer dans la nuance mais c'est
aussi un désavantage parce que je trouve
que tu adoptes ou toujours la même
posture indignés quel que soit le sujet
ce qui fait que quand on est un sujet
très très grave
on ne t'entend plus parce qu'en fait on
a le même degré d'indignation que l'on
que des choses soit importante ou le
soin - et moi il m'arrive d'être
d'accord avec toi mais tu prends une
telle tonalité qu'on a du mal
nos révolutionnaires
du coup c'est compliqué toutefois je
trouve que tu as un excellent camarade
moi je suis arrivé cette année je trouve
que tu m'a très bien accueilli avec
beaucoup de bienveillance et beaucoup de
sang pas de show sont loupés choix je
pense qu'il est il a envoy de mariage on
m'a dit que c'était pour bien me faut en
faire la vague nettement encore trouvé
la mort
[Applaudissements]
gilles ou alors comme tu le sais on a
déjà parlé je suis très souvent d'accord
avec toi tu es souvent dans les extrêmes
mais c'est largement nécessaire la
plupart du temps dites moi ce n'est pas
gilles qui va pécho qui fit autres toute
attente les gars là pour moi c'est zéro
langue de bois était toujours prêt pour
la barca c'est tellement drôle pour moi
je trouve super drôle mais vraiment le
plus drôle de la terre j'en ai jeté
montré une vidéo ce après midi de toi et
moi j'ai adoré je fais plus rôle va te
feras ouais c'est le plus drôle ya là
bas moi j'ai rien alors dans sa jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
segalot plus drôle de la terre alors
qu'est ce qu'on ne ferait que je te bats
tous les jours pour faire dorer les gens
achètent des glaces
[Applaudissements]
vous trouvez que c'est plus drôle c'est
plus drôle du monde il me fait il me
fait rigoler voilà et pour ça je lui
mets un billet sur il alors on se baisse
mais je ne peux pas le livre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne mérite pas le lire voilà non non
non
[Rires]
alors en particulier mont-royal semaine
ça quel sujet ah ouais allez on peut pas
on va en parler à la personne parce que
sa conjointe quatre tours de la fin
alors bernard montiel
alors moi je trouve que tu es le
meilleur chroniqueur mais je veux dire
pourquoi n'ont ils pas apporté un grand
comique qui n'aime rien et ça ça m'amuse
à chaque fois un pacs est l'homme le
plus drôle est là juste après nous et le
monde à l'envers
tu es dévoué corps et âme d'abord à
cyril puis à fatou et c'est très
touchant plusieurs atouts m'amuse
beaucoup à chaque fois j'attends chaque
fois des interventions parce qu'à chaque
fois ça me fait rire à chaque fois ses
explosifs
cette fois c'est n'importe quoi et c'est
drôle t'as pas peur de t'exprimer et de
trancher mais parfois tu deviens moins
crédible parce que trop souvent
caricaturale et en attend on s'attend à
ce que tu vas dire mais je t'aime
beaucoup parce que d'abord mis pendant
la maline bien vos camarades je te bénis
suisse à malte
je vous rappel pour les humoristes y
sont légalement c'est kelly semoun qu'il
alors oui alors il est temps à moi et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut voir
régulièrement dans touche pas à mon
poste est battu et un garçon extrêmement
charmant sais pas quoi étonner les
téléspectateurs mais 3g paquet on se
rend compte qu'on était complet aux gens
qu'on l'a peut être que oui en secret
dans cette émission j'ai là bas avec eux
et qu'ils avaient je comprends pas je
dis non c'est bien mais lui il va je
suis en train de la barre nous ne nous
passe complètement au travers cette
pièce de laurent baffie
oui cette voiture ça tu es charmant tué
attentionné avec le reste de l'équipe ça
c'est vraiment une qualité que je te
reconnais tu mouiller la chemise tu es
un bon petit soldat et un point faible
c'est un point fort c'est effectivement
ce qu'on a dit 110 et ugl donc ça la
fois un point faible évidemment parce
que tu gueules tout le temps et tu mets
tout sur le même niveau mais c'est en
même temps un point fort parce que aussi
on peut avoir des débats animés grâce à
toi parce qu'effectivement en fonction
de ce que tu vas dire nous ça nous
permet de rebondir je crée du débat de
l'animation de la controverse et de la
polémique et donc pour tout ça parce que
c'est aussi ça ne touche pas à mon poste
ben je te mets un excellent
[Applaudissements]
la partie il faut t'il eu à m'envoyer
des messages voulait beaucoup et il ya
beaucoup de messages également sur toi
stéphane de gens qui disent c'est
fragile vétérinaire non parce que tu
marches
oui mais voilà mais on va vous expliquer
c'est quelqu'un qui voit là et de
clôture qu'il aimait ses fans en fait
ils voient la mêlée à lourdes juste
après
[Applaudissements]
il joue même voter die même à jouer nice
mais on a déjà fait des matches entre
les deux où il était était debout a
expliqué marié j'aime bien venir sur les
plateaux et puis sur le court debout
parce que je ne savais pas que le tennis
en fauteuil et n'étaient pas réservés
aux personnes qui étaient en fauteuil au
quotidien il se trouve que moi je suis
en [ __ ] est dommage on gauche au dessus
de salou et j'aimerais bien même que
tout le monde puisse un jour et louise
avait envie de jouer donc le sait la
jambe aussi amputer rappelé à partager
quant à l'excès woods va nous faire une
claque ce soir on tuerait pour une vanne
tout ça bien sûr mais aussi la
particularité du tennis en fauteuil
justement c'est de ne pas mettre les
gens dans des cases il pas faire de
différences quelles que soient nos
différences on joue tous ensemble donc
il y en a qui marche et matt exactement
bah voilà donc vous avez la réponse
qu'il y avait plein de gens qui nous
demandent et jean michel maire sur
gilles verdez oui j l'homme alors tu le
sais je suis peut-être pas proctologue
mais je sais reconnaître un trou du cul
cotonou
[Applaudissements]
on verra bien cette phrase comment est
ce que vous avez dit en fait je suis
peut-être pas proctologue mais je sais
reconnaître un trou du cul quand j'en ai
en face de moi et c'est le cas des cinq
ans mais j'y vois là alors mais je
laisse à 1 au chalut sur facebook
c'était sur une assiette chez mes
parents me suis fait mon temps cet
accrochage est sous licence
alors oui néanmoins je veux être juste
un vrai point fort des jamais malade ça
je reconnais en cinq ans un peu comme
des plantes des plans de l'esa l'aller
salzer mes réserves qui franchissent les
saisons sans jamais perdre de leur
superbe
donc ça je te dis bravo c'est moi même
qui suis pourtant courageux des étapes
sont en revanche pas des gros points
forts ou millions de ton côté bulldogs
sam géronte mais je me suis fait donc
voilà en revanche le plus gênant c'est
que tu m'accuses de rien [ __ ]
mais quand je vois toi le boulot que tu
déploies pour être aussi nul
franchement un éloge quotidien à la
fainéantise donjon félicité jeudi contre
la prochaine a rien fait si le patron de
la corde le plus gênant c'est que
jusqu'à l'année dernière il y avait
juste un simple lécheurs de boules de
sceller l'on parle toujours du match
voilà malheureusement cette année
concurrencé par bernard montiel et passe
surtout par balles chamakh a franchi une
étape supplémentaire c'est que
maintenant tu laisses tu passes police
est là et la pouliche à maurice
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
allez les notes s'il vous plaît à notre
début tous ses chroniqueurs
je pense que vous ces derniers d'accueil